[Applause]
wow
very nice to have you with us
that my friend is a real bit that's a
man's beard right there
that is a very nice beard can we see my
beard one more time and let's try and
see who's got the
look at that look at that
her beard is beating the crap out of my
beard but this this took six months
six months oh okay i wouldn't have that
in six years but we can leave that to
another time this is nice
this is your home town of course yes uh
you're from is it astoria i'm from
queens yeah
queens yeah this is very nice
you uh your family they owned
a bakery there is that right yes in a
story on broadway
and uh it was there for about 60 years
and my father retired it's
it's gone now and what did you ever help
out at the at the bakery i did when i
was a kid i worked in the back
i you know did all sorts of things
only you could make working in a bakery
sounds so sorted somehow
so mysterious delivered cakes i you know
i did
kind of uh cleaning up types of stuff
did you make uh what would you make
pastries donuts did you make uh
i i had to do something i had little
chores i
i had to fill the jelly donuts i i used
to fill the jelly doughnuts i'm sure
i just all right now
i'm sure they have uh uh you know
high-tech ways of doing it now but in
those days it was very basic
uh-huh you had a huge uh
can of jelly right and it had like a
hypodermic on top of it with two
needles right and you'd take a doughnut
in each hand you'd stick it on there and
then you'd
push it down like a dynamite thing right
and the jelly would go into the donut
and it was very exciting
it sounds yeah you make it sound almost
yeah like a
yeah sensual now
[Applause]
now i also if we're going to talk about
your past your real name
if you don't mind me saying was what
ronald
ronald
[Applause]
and i changed it i was in a nightclub
act about 30 years ago and
where you fill jelly donuts on stage
yeah i
danced in the nightclub act and and uh
the lady who was the the star of the
show
said i think i'll call you christopher
so i did
i just just because someone arbitrarily
out of nowhere said i'm calling you
christopher
it's true i said ronald it's hard to say
or something so i called you christopher
right that was it okay that's an
interesting idea they just
that person had a big influence on your
life and probably are they aware is that
person aware that they created the name
christopher walken
sure and uh
yeah it was very quick it was like that
just like that
but i wish it had been chris chris
walken
it's nicer shorter christopher always
looks
like a train you know well you're
in charge here you could say hey from
now on in the next movie i am chris
walken you know i asked to do that
a number of times and they said nope you
know i guess they pay for all those
letters
right right that's it you should change
it to at this point just go like for
blaze walk-ins or something really cool
or what caesar augustus
[Laughter]
wow delusions of grandeur are seeking in
now the last time you were on the show i
remember this very clearly you said
i remember this very well you said i'd
love to someday have
a cooking show and i remember thinking
you've accomplished so much it just
seemed strange to me
that you would you'd want to go do a
cooking show but i thought well i'd
watch christopher walken cooking show
what happened to that idea well i i love
cooking shows i love to watch them
and there's so many different kinds and
in fact since then i did one
i did a show for bravo that was on it
was a half hour thing it was
it was nice
but i'd like to i would like to do a
cooking show or really some sort of
spontaneous show when i was a kid i used
to watch the dean martin
show and you always got the feeling that
he walked in and it just
happened of course that's that's not
true it was probably very well planned
but
right i always i always liked that idea
that the guy walks in and
who knows what's going to happen we got
that here baby i mean nothing we don't
we don't rehearse this thing this is
just
this is just anything i come out here i
mean i don't know what's going to happen
i don't whoa look at that i don't know
what's going to happen
but that that is what's interesting
about this kind of uh
venue it's like watching sports you know
you're not really sure what's going to
happen right
right well it's well and would you do a
kind of show like that would you ever do
like a
a crazy adventure show a show where you
do stunts would you do that
i have an idea to do one for one of
these new rocket roller coasters you
know to go on one i went on one and uh
it was really scary
so you want a show where you just ride
around on a roller coaster
i'm gonna do a different one every week
you know a different roller coaster each
week
fly fishing something like that right
right right
okay right now a lot of it your phone's
gonna be ringing off the hook
now uh we have to talk about the fat boy
slim video which is
everybody's favorite video this year
such a great video
such a great such a great concept so
well
executed i mean you're really you're
dancing up a storm in
in this video it's great to have the
opportunity to do that you know with my
advanced age to do that
and they don't make musical movies so
much anymore so the idea of being able
to do that was great
i've i did a couple of musical movies uh
and uh i guess spike jones must have
seen one of them and uh and he had the
idea and he approached you did you know
fat boy slim nope i didn't uh
no i i should have but my my uh music
knowledge stops uh somewhere in the 70s
right
right so so you weren't but but you you
when you saw the finished product you
must have been delighted yeah it was
terrific
let's just take a quick look at a clip
from this uh
[Music]
you never heard
that's amazing i love i've i've watched
that thing so many times
i really uh
are those are those hard moves to learn
i would love to learn some of those
moves can you show me anything from that
uh can you just just a little something
bro don't show me on that max you need
to
show me show me a little something
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's my i have to say that's my
favorite
[Laughter]
that is my favorite that is my favorite
dance move of all time
that one right there i live in the
country and that's what the raccoons do
at night
only you would look at a raccoon and say
that's a dance move right there
uh america's sweethearts is in theaters
now and the seagull
opens august 12th at the delacorte
theater yes
and people should go and see that it's
always a thrill when you're on